the federal reserve will begin raising
interest rates in march it's a departure
from pandemic era policies that have
been in place since march 2020 pegging
the benchmark rate to zero fed chairman
jerome powell says the move is designed
to temper economic growth americans have
seen decades high inflation rates lately
eating into wage gains and household
budgets the fed chairman
added that he thinks there is quite a
bit of room to raise rates without
threatening the labor market
well i would say
well to help us make sense of all this
we've got stephen beardsley with us from
dw business steve investors around the
world have been eagerly awaiting this
decision from the fed
why is it so important
well it's important because let's start
with the domestic economy right hiking
rates essentially makes borrowing more
expensive when that happens that cuts
into corporate profits and also cuts
into loans that means mortgages car
loans credit cards things like that that
brings down consumer spending so overall
it takes steam out of the american
economy the american economy is the
world's biggest economy and it spills
well out over its borders that means
that any time that economy contracts a
little bit you're going to see a
reaction across the globe now there's
two other things to consider one is that
for exporters into the u.s this could be
good for them because the u.s dollar
should get higher in relation to their
currency that's a good thing for them
but for emerging markets it could be a
bad thing one reason is that many peg
their debt to u.s dollars if the price
of that debt then goes up they have more
to pay back
another reason is that um many have um
they've seen that um what happens is
that when
borrowing rates in the u.s get more
attractive i should say lending rates
you buy a bond for example you're
getting paid more a higher interest rate
for it that money then pulls out of
emerging markets and so that's what
they're going to fear if you're in india
if you're south africa if you're brazil
you're going to be watching closely okay
so there are global implications to this
but
it's really just correcting something in
a situation where there's very high
inflation what does this mean
really how big of a shift is it well in
many ways the fed has been telegraphing
this already for weeks you know there
was some expectation that it could be a
sudden interest rate change that didn't
happen there was an expectation that
perhaps would be a half a percent change
it's only going to be a quarter percent
change most likely so for the most part
markets had already factored a lot of
this in but as you mentioned this is a
shift from two years of a much looser
monetary policy and this is the u.s
basically saying the dynamic has changed
we are now moving on to a post-covet
economy but there are still a lot of
questions that are making markets a
little jittery how many rate cuts are
there going to be how bad is inflation
going to be what's going to curb it so
the dynamic has changed but not everyone
is completely sure what that dynamic
looks like from now on
steve thank you so much steve bearsley
from dw business
you